when boys did you takes out Vanzant
doing Rachel most of its wolf died me
die Me's of all diamonds they're better
looking than the ring car girls well
most of which has the most
redonkulous body and her face is Rishi's
beautiful to ease time she's so
beautiful her body's so ridiculous it's
like are you our person yeah
I'd risk it all for that girl and then
you got paid rands in who's why does it
say 155 she's not 150 fat that's a tight
line you have seen get your [ __ ]
people on the website damn it someone's
an [ __ ] they want to make fun over
155 they could also do another picture
of some girl who works for the like
something with a girlfriend of the web
designers like rays 155 [ __ ] that I'm 45
55 yeah she uh yeah she's easy on the
eyes too yeah she's beautiful yeah
they're both of the gorgeous women it's
crazy though that oast of it's coming
off of that domestic violence thing
where have you seen the video of that
no it's disturbing it's her husband
saying he's gonna kill her it's super
disturbing if you need security Rachel I
am here for you so sad um they have kids
together - it's just so [ __ ] up it's
super dark but to put her on the card
with Greg Hardy that was a giant a lot
of people criticizing that and the UFC
does not give a [ __ ] well the thing is
that Greg Hardy was on the card the card
was set before she got assaulted by her
husband so it was already in place she
was supposed to be in the car they
pulled her from the card when they
thought that she had a broken orbital
bone she went to a different doctor I
guess she got some actual exams and MRIs
and stuff turns out she did never broke
an orbital bone they cleared it a fight
she begged them to let her fight because
she just she doesn't want this to take
her out of fighting is what meets a
gigantic catastrophe a horrible dilemma
in her life it's hard not to root for
her husband hits her beats her up it's
it's awful and she's like I'm not gonna
let this guy stop my career I'm not
gonna let this guy change the path my
life
I'm done with him I want to fight and
she begged them to let her fight and I'm
just saying if I'm the UFC I go alright
Greg Hardy he's not a big draw he's not
he's not a veteran there's nothing going
on here let's just move them to any
other [ __ ] card we have we're
sensitive to this we don't you know it's
tuned in just oh and it's not a big deal
moving to the next car I think they want
some controversy I think they like
controversy I think any sort of press
and they live and die by this negative
press is good press well look at what
the jojo's thing they don't get how
about Conor khabib thing they kept
showing him throwing the the the dolly
at that bus they kept showing it over
and over again the promos into their
pointed you know it kind of works
[ __ ] yeah it worked there was a giant
pay-per-view I mean that was giant it
works so you can't no this one's a
little different like throwing a dolly
through the window with other
professional fighters alright whatever I
watched that I hyped that [ __ ] too with
this one I can't I just can't I come out
I'm not hi Bennett I can't get on board
for it well it's not like Austin it's
just fighting her boyfriend her husband
it'd be cool she was I think he's a
fighter cycle because so far okay what's
breach yard yeah it's trouble not good
the whole thing's so ugly